I just want to take a minute to thank
all of you who don't live in the area I
know on Facebook there was a caravan can
people raise your hands that came via
the Caravan God bless you that was such
a cool thing to do um my next yay my
next guest is an acclaimed an
award-winning radio host on a nationally
syndicated radio uh Network w r his name
is Steve milberg he's a regular
oh look at this we got a little M value
here um he's a columnist for Newsmax
he's a regular on on Fox and he's
obviously a most sought after speaker
Steve oh wow you know standing back here
it's hard to see how far back this
stretch is but it's stretches far back
thank you all and thanks to Pamela for
having me speak I appreciate
it I want to do something at the start
of my little chat that I do at the end
of every one of my shows um probably the
only show in uh the world where we do
five seconds of Silent
prayer um there's been a controversy and
obviously by my presence here I don't
believe it's it's all that valid but as
Pam did when this rally started I want
to once again cuz lot of time has passed
by just bow our heads for a few seconds
and remember what took place here nine
years
ago thank
you uh ladies and gentlemen we are at a
Crossroads we are at a watershed moment
in our country's
history I have a 11-year-old soon to be
11-year-old son and I fear for for his
future and let me tell you
why the latest
rationale for having this mosque here
according to Imam
rou is that if he moves it
now he doesn't know what the radical
islamists might
do we don't care care we don't
care the day that we start worrying
about the actions of terrorists and
that's what they
are over the concerns of our own safety
our own country our own decency we are
finished who would have thought on 911
or 912 or 913 if I would have told you
that there would be a mosque going up
here 10 years later with an opening date
of
911 you would have locked me up in a
rubber room but you know
what there were people as they are today
they played a good game back then those
on the left those in the media but I say
every every single person from Mayor
Bloomberg on up or down or sideways who
wants this mosque built here would have
welcomed it on 911
also this is a separate issue but it's
exactly the
same
topic the man the pastor who was going
to burn the
Quran Pastor Terry Jones I didn't
condone it I wouldn't participate in it
but I respected his right to do it we've
had crucifixes in jars of urine we've
had the elephant dung on the Virgin Mary
we've had the US
military destroy
Bibles in
Afghanistan but this man Terry Jones who
called off his Karan burning
got visits from the
FBI a call from the defense
secretary had his website closed
down and of course the president of the
United States the Secretary of State and
the top General in Afghanistan all said
if a US Soldier dies because of this
Quan burning the pastor will have blood
on his
hands baloney the terrorists would have
the blood on their
hands what has happened to this
country where are we where are we
going if we allow this mosque to be
built because we don't know what the
radical terrorists might do if we move
it if we stop Karan burnings or anything
because we don't know what the radical
terrorists will do
what's next what's next what's
next where's our freedom where's our
country we have a
president who is more concerned about
appeasing radical
Islam than doing what's right and
protecting the freedoms of every
American citizen he says build the MOs
but to burn the Quran would be
insensitive it's a stunt whose side is
he
on ladies and gentlemen we are at a
Crossroads we cannot be intimidated let
them call us whatever they want let them
call us big
islamophobes whatever do you
know that for the last year such
statistics are available 2008 FBI stats
now one hate crime against anybody is
one too much don't get me wrong however
we're such an islamophobic country every
Network's doing specials islamophobia
the Imam and his wife were all
islamophobic ladies and gentlemen there
were over
3,000 so-called hate crimes classified
in 2008 against blacks 2500 against gays
over a thousand against Jews
106 against Muslims there's your Islamic
ISL islamophobic Nation ladies and
gentlemen that's a false premise don't
believe
it I just can't tell you how proud I am
to be here and of the turnout and of
every single one of you here because I
know I know that there are good people
who differ and I know it's not easy for
everybody because you got to go home to
dinner tables and co-workers and
families who say you know what Bloomberg
and Obama say but they are dead wrong
and I will say I will say that
the people I'll say it again the people
who want this mosque built it is a
symbol of
conquering it is a symbol to the Muslim
world that they conquered and let me
leave you with this someone inform me of
this and take it for what it's worth
when you get home Google the Quran
translation this is called project 51
why go to I know back to go to chapter
51 in the Quran and go go to the address
44 to 46 chapter 51: 44 45 and 46 I'll
leave you with that tease and you will
understand why they will never ever move
the sight of this mosque it must be
built here or it's worthless to
them ladies and
gentlemen
I got to tell you one other
disappointment Fox News W did a poll
they wanted to know who was responsible
for ratcheting up the Quan burning
controversy was it the Obama
Administration was it the media or was
it the pastor Terry
Jones I was on the treadmill I almost
fell off they left out one very
important choice and it happened to be
the correct answer
the people responsible for the Quran
controversy are the radical Islamic
terrorists those who threaten violence
over the burning of a
book and if we don't understand that we
are done God bless you all keep the
faith